queremos ver cómo desarrollar este
binomio elevado al cuadrado es decir a x
+ ve todo elevado al cuadrado te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trates de
descubrir cómo expresar este binomio al
cuadrado por supuesto en términos de a x
y de b
aunque hoy vamos a hacerlo juntos
entonces la idea es que tenemos este
binomio elevado al cuadrado es decir
tenemos ese mismo binomio multiplicado
consigo mismo dos veces verdad así que
vamos a copiar ese mismo binomio tenemos
xy déjenme de una vez poner aquí a x
para no tener más problemas con los
colores muy bien y tendremos a x + b x a
x + b y ahora vamos a empezar a
desarrollar esa expresión muy bien
entonces por ejemplo podríamos tomar
primero el a x y en la x y
multiplicarlos muy bien si los
multiplicamos que obtenemos tendremos a
x elevado al cuadrado vamos con un
siguiente término vamos a multiplicar
ahora a x por b muy bien y si
multiplicamos a x por b obtendremos
de x muy bien ahora sigamos con este
siguiente termino este sería b por a x
es lo mismo que a b x verdad entonces
tenemos dos copias de esa expresión y
finalmente vamos a multiplicar b por b y
eso simplemente será be cuadrada muy
bien así que vamos a seguir digamos
desarrollando esto vamos a hacerlo paso
por paso aquí tendremos a x al cuadrado
y aquí podemos juntar estos dos términos
que son iguales tendremos dos veces a x
b por x y finalmente sumamos de cuadrada
muy bien y todavía podríamos hacer un
último paso simplemente desarrollando
este cuadrado que tenemos aquí y será a
cuadrada x cuadrada
+ 2 ave x y sumando al final de cuadrada
muy bien entonces ahora con esto podemos
ver el patrón que hay para digamos para
el cuadrado de cualquier binomio por
ejemplo digamos que tenemos el siguiente
binomio tendremos 25 x cuadrada más 20 x
más 4 muy bien y digamos que alguien
llega y te dice bueno intenta factorizar
este este trinomio verdad entonces te
invito a que hagas una pausa y que lo
intentes hacer por tu cuenta verdad
esencialmente utilizando este este este
método que hemos hecho aquí
entonces el punto es que debería encajar
el patrón que hemos desarrollado antes
verdad entonces vamos a factorizar esto
y podemos ver que este primer término
este primer mono mió en realidad se ve
como un cuadrado verdad en realidad es
5x todo eso elevado al cuadrado entonces
podemos escribirlo así esto es 5x
elevado al cuadrado y luego podemos ver
que aquí tenemos 4 verdad de hecho
tenemos más 4 verdad y eso lo podemos
ver simplemente como 2 al cuadrado
verdad de hecho voy a dejar más espacio
2 elevado al cuadrado verdad entonces
ahora lo que tenemos en medio debería
encajar con nuestro patrón que tenemos
aquí verdad sería el doble de a por b
por equis en este caso hay cinco veces 2
el doble de 5 por 2 sería 2 por 5 sería
10 por 2 sería 20 entonces tendré
justamente que 20 x es 2 por a por b por
equis verdad entonces esto será vamos a
escribirlo esto será dos veces 2 por 5 x
multiplicado todavía por 2 verdad que
sería b x x y finalmente sumamos esto
entonces podemos ver esta expresión
tomando a igual a 5 b igualados verdad
entonces según nuestro patrón que hemos
encontrado verdad esto será igual a un
binomio al cuadrado es decir esto era un
trinomio cuadrado perfecto y esto será
igual a 5 x + 2 y todo eso elevado al
cuadrado muy bien así que el punto de
hacer todo esto es empezar a reconocer
cuando tenemos un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto verdad sobre todo cuando el
coeficiente principal que en este caso
sería a cuadrada no es 1